PICKED.
THAT'S STILL SOMETHING WE DON'T
KNOW.
BRET?
>> Bret: PHIL KEATING, LIVE IN
PARKLAND, THANK YOU.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS OFFERING
FAMILIES AND SURVIVORS, QUOTE,
WHATEVER YOU NEED.
WHATEVER WE CAN DO TO EASE YOUR
PAIN.
ONE THING HE IS NOT OFFERING, AT
LEAST NOT YET, A NEW DIALOGUE ON
GUNS.
SOMETHING OTHERS ARE DEMANDING.
KEVIN CORK IS AT THE HOUSE
TONIGHT.
GOOD EVENING, KEVIN.
>> Reporter: GOOD EVENING, BRET.
THE PRESIDENT IS EXPECTED TO
VISIT THE HIGH SCHOOL AT
PARKLAND.
WE HAVEN'T NAILED DOWN THE
TIMELINE ON THAT VISIT.
AS YOU PROBABLY KNOW, HIS RESORT
AT MARA
AT MAR-A
AT MAR-A-L
AT MAR-A-LAG
AT MAR-A-LAGO,
AT MAR-A-LAGO, H
AT MAR-A-LAGO, HE
AT MAR-A-LAGO, HE T
AT MAR-A-LAGO, HE TAL
AT MAR-A-LAGO, HE TALKE
AT MAR-A-LAGO, HE TALKED
AT MAR-A-LAGO, HE TALKED A
AT MAR-A-LAGO, HE TALKED ABO
AT MAR-A-LAGO, HE TALKED ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED THERE YESTERDAY
AND TOLD AMERICA'S CHILDREN IN
PARTICULAR, YOU ARE NEVER ALONE,
AND YOU NEVER WILL BE.
>> WE MOURN FOR ALL OF THOSE WHO
LOST THEIR LIVES.
WE COMFORT THE GRIEVING AND THE
WOUNDED.
>> Reporter: A DAY AFTER A
GUNMAN KILLED AT LEAST 17 PEOPLE
AT A FLORIDA HIGH SCHOOL,
PRESIDENT TRUMP PLEDGED HIS
ADMINISTRATION WOULD ACT.
>> WE ARE COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH STATE AND LOCAL LEADERS TO
HELP SECURE OUR SCHOOLS, AND
TACKLE THE DIFFICULT ISSUE OF
MENTAL HEALTH.
>> Reporter: NOTABLY, THE
PRESIDENT DID NOT MENTION THE
ISSUE OF GUN CONTROL OR NEW GUN
LAWS DURING HIS ADDRESS TO THE
NATION.
AND HIS REMARKS TODAY, ATTORNEY
GENERAL JEFF SESSIONS STAYED ON
MESSAGE, SAYING THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT WOULD PARTNER WITH
OTHER FEDERAL AGENCIES.
>> TO STUDY THE INTERSECTION OF
MENTAL HEALTH AND CRIMINALITY
AND IDENTIFY, AND HOW WE CAN
STOP PEOPLE BEFORE THESE HEINOUS
CRIMES OCCUR.
>> Reporter: BUT FOR A TIME
THURSDAY, TREASURY SECRETARY
STEVE MNUCHIN APPEARED TO MOVE
AWAY FROM THE TOPIC --
>> PERSONALLY I THINK THE GUN
VIOLENCE, IT'S A TRAGEDY WHAT
WE'VE SEEN YESTERDAY.
AND I WOULD URGE CONGRESS TO
LOOK AT THESE ISSUES.
>> Reporter: HOWEVER, LATER, HIS
OFFICE CLARIFIED THE REMARKS
SAYING THERE WAS NO DAYLIGHT
BETWEEN HIM AND THE PRESIDENT.
THE ADMINISTRATION'S FOCUS ON
THE POSSIBLE MENTAL STATE OF THE
SHOOTER, RATHER THAN THE WEAPON
USED IN THE ATTACK, IS NOT NEW.
AFTER A TEXAS CHURCH SHOOTING
THAT CLAIMED 26 LIVES, THE
PRESIDENT SAID, "THIS ISN'T A
GUN SITUATION."
AFTER THE LAS VEGAS SHOOTER
KILLED 58 AND LEFT NEARLY 900
OTHERS INJURED, THE PRESIDENT
CALLED THE SHOOTER DEMENTED AND
A VERY SICK INDIVIDUAL.
THE PARK LAND SHOOTING JUST THE
LATEST IN A STRING OF DEADLY
VIOLENCE TO STRIKE AMERICA'S
SCHOOL CHILDREN.
WITH MORE THAN TWO DOZEN FATAL
ACTIVE SHOOTING INCIDENTS SINCE
COLUMBINE IN 1999.
THE APPARENT EMPHASIS ON MENTAL
HEALTH RATHER THAN GUNS DRAW
HEALTH RATHER THAN GUNS DRA
HEALTH RATHER THAN GUNS DREW
HEALTH RATHER THAN GUNS DREW A
COMMENT FROM BLUMENTHAL.
>> TALKING ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH
IS SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH.
IT HAS TO BE FOLLOWED BY ACTION.
THE
TH
THE PRESIDENT HAS TO LEAD OR GET
OUT OF THE WAY.
>> I WOULD RATHER PASS GUN
LEGISLATION THAN WIN THE
ELECTION.
BECAUSE PEOPLE DIE FROM THIS.